follow the data that will give you a
very clear indication of which
countries are experiencing spikes that
it's easily available
check the websites and that will show
you what country is
likely to be affected and if that
country is affected
what steps the british government will
take in imposing quarantine we've seen
it happening very quickly
with places like spain and france each
week
the government is adding all removing
countries
according to the data now if we have a
look at what's happening here
these are the confirmed cases the weekly
rate between 24th
and 30th of august and this tells you
exactly which countries
are experiencing the highest outbreaks
in infections you can see
spain there the dark blue country now
each week the government adds or removed
countries according
to the data now spain is already the
worst affected we've seen that there
so the darker the color the higher the
one-week
infection rates now with spain it was
more than 110 cases per 100
000 in the last seven days the
government has said a rate of around 20
cases per 100 000
could trigger quarantine which is one
reason why these countries in blue
have already been removed from the safe
list and you were asking about portugal
you can see it there
21.1 which was only recently returned to
the list
it's seen an increase in cases again and
also
if you look at ireland they're 16.1 it's
also close
to that threshold of 20 but countries
like greece
and italy and turkey are less likely to
require a quarantine
unless of course those cases there start
climbing
sharply here you can see the change in
the previous seven days
the darker colors show the biggest
increases and france and some balkan
countries stand out
italy has doubled its rate in the last
week alone
and keep your eyes on gibraltar too a
lot of talk about people being asked to
quarantine after visiting there
despite its role as a british territory